can you describe someone that you love I
love the way she makes my heart feel I
love the warmth that spreads throughout
my chest when I look at her I
I love how inspiring she is and
I'm excited to see who she becomes
[Music]
hummingbird is a good way to describe
her because even though they kind of
come and go really quickly it's like
like you know when you see him you be
like oh my god look at the hummingbird
and that's my sister because it's like
oh my gosh like there she is
and she's just she's really unique and
and she's also like loves flowers when I
see hummingbirds and flowers they're
just really interesting and colorful you
know I think I described them as
[Music]
as you know like a peach I like the
perfect ripeness they've it's just the
right amount of sweetness and the right
amount of the tart and they just this is
bringing so much joy to my life and
every like moment with them is just
perfect it's like it's it it's as peak
ripeness
[Music]
I mean okay I love my friends but I'm
gonna go with like my dad okay
the only way I can describe my dad is
that he's an [ __ ] but it's like the
fun kind of [ __ ] you know what I mean
it's it's kind of mean to say but he's
really an [ __ ] like he likes pranking
people so it's weird saying that because
like dude he's it kind of sucks saying
that my dad's an [ __ ] because he has
Stage four lung cancer he's the sweetest
thing that's ever come into my life and
I'm so thankful for him and you know
like he's he's doing what dealing with
legal a lot of stuff in his life but I
still think that he's the greatest thing
ever and there's no words like put him
to justice so yeah I love the way that
Brooke looks at me when I'm driving but
weird little gesture she does it makes
me feel good inside it's nice warm it
warms me up I'm driving and it lets me
know that someone cares about me but
she's you know messy of my arm and stuff
and it's a nice beat
[Music]
so they actually talk when I'm taking a
photo and that looks like like screaming
and like saying hello even though it's
not a video they like see me doing
something but like then that's how me to
do it so if I'm going to go drink water
they're like oh you should go drink some
water person it's my parents
[Music]
she's the only person I know that can
dance and sing better than anybody but
also kick-ass in a courtroom so that's
what I've got for that one marina
doesn't have to wear too much makeup
natural beauty
[Music]
I know physically that she's got a big
heart
very compassionate
[Music]
she does make a pretty good dance
partner
well there's two people that I love okay
um one of them is named Lizzie she has
green pants
but she's vegetarian her sometimes vegan
I don't know I don't really know my
situation but she has black hair she's
funny and she lives in Paris and then I
have another friend named Evelyn I love
her too she's wearing a yellow mustard
shirt and she has long black hair and
she's super white she's hilarious too
and she loves me full bottle um love
means by the way this is my birthday and
they brought me on this trip
so that's why I love them so much
there's an artist in Brazil she's called
my tease at Mom's and she sings from her
hearts I love her voice it sounds like
velvet in a sound and
when I went to her show it was like two
months ago it was one of the best
moments of my life she's amazing like if
I had to choose one special person I
would just my little sister Carla I've
noticed that she just started middle
school and she's been very down on
herself and she seems to look up to me a
lot and I don't know why she looks up to
me I think she's a better person than I
am really I think she's always positive
and she always has the right intentions
and she never talked about about people
I just want to say that she's very
special to me and I love her so much I
just got out of a relationship so it's
hard to answer but she's very
understanding actually help me find my
sexuality
just someone that is
able to be there for you while you're
still trying to find yourself
and no matter what everyone else is
saying around you
she still has her back she he whoever oh
my ex-wife
not anymore can you describe why you
loved her wow it was a good-looking
woman she had a good attitude I like
that
and I like the rest of the girls I ever
dated how is she different she didn't
take it all to the heart and these two
you know you tell my joke and they don't
get it and then they can kill you for
that
she got you Joe yeah she liked my jokes
[Music]
kind of busty her cuz I'm out of the guy
I know it's okay I'm better I think uh
you know not as much as before you know
now take a like you know I don't want
nobody to break my heart again go on
with life with me you know what I mean
she is extremely sweet and unconditional
with her love she always looks at me
like I'm the top of the world and it
doesn't matter what I've done or where
I've been and I think the most unique
thing about her is her hair she's really
dark black curly thick hair and she has
four legs and she is the light of my
life and the most unconditional loving
person child being whatever you want to
call her that I've ever known and I'm
you know where my husband is what I call
an accidental Buddhist he doesn't
practice any particular religion he
doesn't subscribe to any particular
dogma or belief system but he is one of
the happiest people I know and lives
undeniably in the moment at all times I
love that he reads to me so I can fall
asleep I love that he makes me laugh
when I'm feeling sick I love that he
supports me and always likes to do
whatever I want to do so that's always
nice too I love that he loves me I love
how she has a million questions and she
expects me the answers she's always
trying to make me see that I can do
things just to make myself happy and
that that's okay
and I'm still learning that from her and
she's
[Music]
it's an amazing person a little
subscriber she's the best person that I
know I love my dad
[Music]
is
the most liberal conservative first that
I know it's the most unique way I can
describe it
my mom is someone who I really adore and
I'm tired and I love so much and that's
because over the past year and a half
she's been going through a lot with her
health and the way her bravery and how
she's handled it and how she's just
conquered it has really just inspired me
and she's been strong for my family and
the best way to describe her is just my
superhero she's my mom and I love her I
have loved her since we were probably in
the first grade and we've spent all
these years together she has the most
beautiful singing voice she should have
been a professional my goal is to get
her on the stage down here at Balboa
Park and have her sing something
best friends for life yes for strong
winds that will only seven seas
background hi all those things that
don't she can you describe someone that
you love
mm I mean depends like there's like the
three sides to the triangle of love like
passion intimacy and like commitment
it's like if you're experiencing a love
that just kind of has like one or two
other sides you can describe it like
pretty accurately but if it's like real
consummate love it's like it's like just
an emotion it's hard to convey that
unless you like crazy linguist is like
the most insane [ __ ] like I can't
really describe it like I just sophomore
in college doing science he's like I
don't do anything with words so no I
can't I can't describe
[Music]
before you go there's one favor I want
to ask of you this is probably the best
way you guys can help me grow my channel
as a creator and I hope I'm not asking
for too much but I was wondering if you
guys could choose a couple of your
favorite episodes on my channel and
share them with friends family members
people on social media the more people
you share it with the better other than
that I hope you guys liked this episode
I hope that you'll hit the like button
if you liked this episode and you'll let
me know down in the comments and follow
me on Instagram that's pretty much it
thank you guys again for everything and
I'll see you next time
[Music]